i
[Música]
ah
en nueva yor las primeras escuelas ya
han abierto sus puertas este mismo lunes
en medio de un gran optimismo pero
también de preocupación cuando solo los
más pequeños los alumnos de prekinder y
de educación especial han vuelto a las
aulas en una vuelta al cole que se va a
hacer de manera escalonada se espera que
al final de la semana 90.000 niños se
hayan vuelto ya a sus clases y a pesar
de que la gran manzana parece estar
conteniendo la pandemia aquí el nivel de
infección diario está por debajo del 1
por ciento los planes de la vuelta al
cole se han cambiado ya no volverán
todos los alumnos el 21 de septiembre
como se había previsto sino que se hará
en tres fases una primera fase que hemos
visto este lunes la siguiente el 29 de
septiembre y los más mayores volverán al
cole el 1 de octubre en estos primeros
días hemos visto a unos pequeños muy
concienciados con el uso de la
mascarilla y unos profesores muy
pendientes de que se cumplan esas
medidas sanitarias de distanciamiento
social y toma constante de temperatura
para que nada estropee esta vuelta al
cole tan esperada
[Música]
después de casi seis meses sin vuelos
internacionales colombia acogió el
sábado 19 de septiembre el primer
trayecto más allá de sus fronteras fue a
fort lauderdale en eeuu y salió desde
cartagena de indias fue el primer vuelo
antes de la reapertura del 21 de
septiembre cuando recuperaron su
actividad los aeropuertos de bogotá la
capital de colombia cali y medellín sin
embargo los destinos son limitados por
el momento además de eeuu se puede volar
a ecuador méjico bolivia brasil
república dominicana y guatemala por su
parte las conexiones con europa todavía
tendrán que esperar para entrar a
colombia los pasajeros sólo tendrán que
hacer una cuarentena de 14 días si
acceden sin prueba pcr pero a partir del
30 de septiembre el test será
obligatorio y tendrá que ser realizado
antes de 96 horas de la salida del vuelo
los aeropuertos en colombia fueron
cerrados el 23 de marzo poco después del
inicio de la pandemia y después de que
las autoridades consideras en que los
vuelos internacionales fueron la
principal puerta de entrada del cobi 19
a colombia
[Música]
el gobierno de colas maduro sigue
aplicando su plan de flexibilización de
la cuarentena llamado 77 que fue
impuesto el pasado mes de junio son
siete días de flexibilización y siete
días de confinamiento esta semana la ha
denominado de flexibilización amplia y
general
esto significa que 24 sectores
económicos del país podrán abrir
anteriormente sólo 11 tenían el derecho
a trabajar el presidente nicolás maduro
luego de seis meses de cuarentena dijo
que tomó la medida para mover la
economía sólo están exceptuados de este
plan los municipios fronterizos de los
estados táchira zulia apure y bolívar
que se mantienen bajo la cuarentena
radical en esa zona sólo trabajan las
actividades esenciales como alimentos
transporte y medicinas la
flexibilización de la cuarentena se da
en el contexto de una fuerte escasez de
gasolina en todo el país así como las
fallas en los servicios como la
electricidad
[Música]